the rest of the Dems are insisting that
open borders and mass migration is not
only a good thing but it is profoundly
essentially American here we have
Democrat Congressman Max Frost to my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle let's be honest with immigrants
who deserve better than what you're
offering them don't welcome immigrants
if you plan to reject them if you keep
pushing your bigoted hr2 bill then also
pass this bill I've taken the liberty of
drafting it for you it removes the
Statue of Liberty our largest symbol
that tells people to come here this is
who you are removing the fabric of
America so I want to know which
Republican who supports and voted for
hr2 will introduce this bill the Statute
of Liberty doesn't actually tell
foreigners to come here certainly
doesn't tell them to come here in in
violation of our laws